>> Okay. So thank
you for great days.
So, before Sandy drags
me off the stage,
I really want to
thank him as well.
So, of course, him and his team,
I know Mariah has kept on
keeping me on schedule,
but really Sandy has also put
a huge amount of time
and effort into this.
So, I think he really
deserves a round of applause.
So thank you Sandy.
I also want to extend
special thanks
to my partner in
crime here Dan Fei,
who was the co-PC chair,
and we had many short
term discussions
and phone calls and everything.
So, really thanks.
You really made it
happen and it was
a great event. So thanks Dan.
But of course also
I would love to
thank all of you for coming here,
again busy schedules,
but these last two days
were really amazing.
The amount of energy
was just outstanding,
and so, I think you should give
yourself a round of
applause as well.
So thank you very much.
Okay. So, I showed
this slide yesterday
in order to introduce
Mark Russinovich and Azure,
and I'm actually going to
use or I'm going to
tee off this slide,
use this slide to tee off
my final closing thoughts.
So, the way we at Microsoft
mostly think about
this slide and you've heard
this slogan many times,
is intelligent edge
intelligent cloud.
So, we essentially say well,
there's this public cloud,
everything that we don't fully
understand and has some shape
right in this cloud form,
maybe even private cloud,
that's our Intelligent Cloud,
abundant computing and
whatsoever and we put it there.
Then we have all these devices
and our mobile phones,
our toy cars that are connected
to the Internet and
that's what we call
the Intelligent Edge, right?
We also reason about
it and why we do this.
We have the Intelligent Edge,
is where we collect the data,
that's where we make decisions
because the decisions have
to be implemented fast,
and also this is the environment
we trust a little bit more.
Our phone is with us.
We trust it a little bit more.
Of course it can be hacked.
But but it's close
to us whereas the cloud
is somehow remote.
The cloud is where we
have abundant computing.
We typically don't
trust what's going on.
It has higher latency,
but that's where we
do data analytics.
That's where we do training.
So, that's how we mostly think
about this world with all the,
I almost pressed
the red button here but I
didn't have to go back one slide.
So, this is how we mostly
think about the world and
it's nicely petition and so on.
So my final thought is
that actually because of
what Albert was talking about
all this cable and
hyper-connectivity,
I think we now have
something else.
Essentially, this is
all moving together,
and it's transforming to
one big supercomputer
that we sometimes and
you might have heard
that term as well
called the global
AI supercomputer.
This is like think of everything
all the computing
devices somehow they're
all connected through
the Internet,
through the same logical fabric.
Of course there is
their virtual nets
as Albert mentioned yesterday,
but somehow they're
all connected,
and this is one big machine.
I think this is the picture
or the metaphor that I
would like to use for
these brief closing
remarks before
Sandy catches me off
the stage because he wants
to go home, I assume.
We all want to go home.
So, there are essentially
two perspectives on
this supercomputer.
There's the perspective that
we probably are familiar with,
is the internal perspective
where we essentially look at
the components at each
of a set of components
of this supercomputer.
Let's say, a drone that
communicates with
a mobile phone for example.
But there's also
the external perspective,
where we really look at
this as one machine.
Just think of it
this is one machine.
Just as today, your phone or
even your car is not
just one CPU process.
So your car probably
has 100 CPUs inside,
and your PC has a GPU inside,
has several cores inside,
in future it might have
some accelerators inside.
So, just think of this now
as this one big machine.
Yeah? The important
thing and I'll
come to that I'll first go to
the internal perspectives,
that most of the people
in the world are
not Systems Researchers like us.
Yeah? So, Systems Researchers
look at the components and
somehow how they interact,
but most of the
people on this planet
look at the experience
that they have
with computing as a kind of
one experience as one machine.
In the old days it was a PC
and then it was a phone,
but now it is really all of
these devices that create
these experiences.
So, I want to go
a little bit through
these two perspectives and
start with the
internal perspective,
because most of the talks
that we had here and most of
the discussion that we
had here was really on
the internal perspective.
That is great to see and
it's all great work.
This is what our everyday job
and it's a lot of fun and we
should definitely and most
definitely continue that, right?
So, all the work we
have done in improving
components or connections or
pieces of this big supercomputer,
those are still important
and highly relevant and we
still want to keep
that work alive.
There are a lot of new
ideas and that is why I
felt the summit was so exciting,
because even though
that we've been
doing this for I
don't know 50 years,
60 years since for
nine months or so,
obviously I haven't
been doing it for
60 years and most of you not.
There is continuously new ideas
exciting ideas to do this,
and we've heard many of them.
There was a whole track
on AI for systems.
There was work on how
to predict workloads,
how to predict what
is the best decision,
and this is really exciting
and that didn't definitely
not exist five or
even three years ago,
this kind of thinking and work.
There is this whole line
of work of synthesizing
code or instance
optimized system.
Yesterday there was this session
which was talking about
learned indexes where
you use machine learning
to create data structures
and algorithms.
There was talk
about software 2.0,
a very new way to
create software which
actually I'll come to and might
actually become relevant.
There are systems for AI.
We now have a, I'm
a database person.
So, we optimize database systems
because we know the operations
that we need to do.
With AI you also know
the operations we need to do.
We had a lot of this in
several talks during
those faculty summit
focusing on that.
This is a whole new great kind of
mining pool for ideas
and great work to be.
Custom hardware, security, we
talked a lot about enclaves,
about Intel SGX or
even Hyper- FPGAs,
hardware software co-design,
cross-layer optimizations.
Some of these ideas are very
new and some of these ideas are
old and done in
a new context and all
that is very exciting,
and we should
continue to do that.
But what I would like to focus
on is the external perspective,
what really society expects
from us or the what,
I mean what we
usually say as what
my grandmother expects
from me to deliver.
So the first, we're
creating or I mean we
are a big part of creating
this big machine,
and the first question
that society asks us,
what is the value
of this machine?
I think we should also
step back and think
about that as well,
and there's all these questions.
So, those are technical
questions as well.
How do I program this machine?
How do I use this machine?
With my telephone, with
my smartphone it's very clear.
With my PC it's
a screen it's the keyboard,
it has speakers.
The interaction modalities
are very clear.
Here, there's so many
interaction modalities
and they keep on growing.
The programming and
the interaction
becomes very, very interesting,
because of course we
want to program
experiences for the user,
but what is the set of
the devices that the user
has available for the experience
that I want to program?
I know very little
about the context and
even the computational context
of my application for my user,
and that is obviously going
to make my programming-
My task of programming
application were difficult.
Every user, probably there are
no two users in
this room that have
exactly the same set of
devices in their
normal everyday life.
Then of course,
the big questions are;
what can I do with
this machine that I
couldn't do before?
This is not only
for us and I'll get
to answer that question
because most
of the really interesting
things that we're
doing are solving
the world's biggest problems,
climate change, and so on.
It's not that we
can do this alone,
even as computer
science community,
but of course we
have to reach out to
other scientific disciplines and
also to the rest of society.
Then of course, maybe one of
the most exciting questions
for us and I'm not saying
that these are easy to
answer questions is;
what can't I do?
And what I would like to do?
So, that's the first thing I
think that we have to deliver.
The second thing of course,
that's the plus side,
and we all know that
society expects from us
also to very carefully
think about the minus side.
So, we really have to think
about the risk and
its security was
a huge topic here over
these last two days.
So, what can go wrong?
How do I hack this machine?
Of course, this machine,
every year, there are
nine billion new
micro-controllers produced.
So, every year, we are producing
at least nine billion
attack points,
and so, we can leak
information that we
don't want to leak.
Somebody can change
our information.
I'm not particularly
happy if somebody,
like I want to go
to the Olympic Peninsula
on the weekend,
I've booked the ferry boat,
and if somebody
changes the ticket
of my ferry boat
without me noticing,
I'm not going to be very happy.
A lot of this,
if you think about it,
it's going to be one of
the big questions is about
how to compose security.
We haven't talked
much about that here,
but it is something that we at
Microsoft really
struggle with greatly,
because we have many great ideas
to many great protocols,
and many great ideas to solve
a specific security problem
in a particular context.
But now, if you put a puzzle,
all of these contexts together,
and look at different
paths through it,
that's where the big problems
come in security.
Of course, there's
a whole regulation aspect,
how do we as Microsoft
as a big problem for
us prove that we are GDPR
compliant for example?
We want to be GDPR compliant.
It's really something, and we're
doing huge efforts to do that,
but of course, we want
to prove and we're proud
of all the efforts that we're
doing. We want to prove that.
On the other side, of course,
we want to understand regulators
and when they specify
regulations like GDPR,
and other regulations.
Of course, there's
the normal systems aspect
of this and so
there's a plus side,
a minus side, and of course,
we need to optimize this machine.
Of course, any of us
work on this, again,
at different aspects and
that's where things again,
if you optimize
this machine at some point,
that might not matter
in the bigger context.
But really, now computing
is the biggest energy
consumer on the planet,
and you know all
about these stories
about that Bitcoin and Ethereum,
the proof of work.
This is a major
sustainability and
climate change is starting to
be a factor because of
the economics of consuming
energy in this thing.
So, we have a huge
responsibility here to
optimize for the
sustainability of the planet.
So, there are
all these other questions
because this is a machine
that is not owned by anybody.
It's owned by all of us and
some pieces might be owned
by different people.
Microsoft might have
a fairly big share
because it has many servers,
but overall, this is still tiny
compared to the magnitude
of this big machine.
So, all of these
questions are pretty
big and it's not really,
yeah, you would say,
okay, that's a good
research topic but then,
if you think about
it five minutes,
you'll say, well,
really, what can I do?
So, what I'm going to do is,
I'm just going to give
you some examples
how we at Microsoft
Research have been
going about this addressing
some of these questions in a way.
So, we don't have
access to this machine.
It's woven into our societies
and into our planet,
and into our everyday lives.
We cannot really access it.
It's invisible, and
it's not a test beds.
We cannot put it into a lab
and replicate it in the lab.
Even with all the Cloud computing
and simulation that we have,
even that, we cannot simulate
it and we cannot
replicate it in a lab.
So, the way to
really go about it,
is to take a slice
of this machine.
That's a very different
thinking that
we have typically in
systems research,
where in systems research,
you usually take
a vertical slice.
You look at the stack,
and then you take a piece,
a vertical slice of the stack.
But, what I'm going to talk
about or what I'm going to
give examples are slices that go,
not necessary vertically
and horizontally,
they go in zigzag through
what this machine is about.
I'm going to start
with one example,
which might be surprising
here, but I'll do it,
which is how we thought
about education and one of
the examples where
Microsoft engaged.
All of these examples are
also examples that are not
MS internal or even
Microsoft Internal.
They are all examples where
we reached out with somebody
else in the world,
mostly in academia.
So, the first one
was about education.
The reason why I'm saying this,
this is an interesting piece
of schooling hardware.
This Microbit, I don't
know who has heard of it.
It's a very simple processor
with some interactions.
It has some lights and it
has a little bit of sensing.
This is a piece of
hardware that BBC in
the UK has advertised
and has shipped to
schools and is available,
you can buy it,
you can get a kit.
But it also comes,
and this is the right side
of that picture,
with a programming model.
So, it's education
how to bring people,
how to convince
people and children,
in this case really children,
how to make them
program of course,
in a playful manner.
This is not real applications,
and this is really not going to
solve climate change
this application.
But they learn
programming through
a Web interface through
a graphical thing
and I'm showing a little bit
some piece of code,
and then they can run it,
and they can experience a device.
The concept is called
Physical Programming.
It's one way how hardware with
software engineering
somehow comes together,
hardware design with
software engineering,
to create something in
the educational space.
I'm going to give
you another example
that we had this
morning, actually,
heard it twice this
morning because of
technical issues and
it's exactly that slide.
Of course, I stole that slide,
I'm allowed to do that
as a Lab Director,
is the FarmBeats project.
Again, my point here is,
it is motivated by
a real-world problem and then,
it looks and it changes
through the components
that are needed in
this global AI supercomputer,
and there's a lot of AI here,
but there's a lot of
systems work in here.
So, what essentially happens is,
the drone flies over
a field, take pictures,
these pictures are
a little bit pre-filter
but they are going
through this TV white spaces
network to some edge,
device, or a gateway where
there are further process.
There's some AI done,
they then go to
the Cloud where there's
a little bit more
comprehensive AI done
in order to understand what
is going on in this field.
What is the humidity,
what is the water saturation
of the soil in that field?
We have this demo
of how the FPGA can
actually do this real-time AI
on image processing.
Then, of course, it goes
back to the gateway,
in order to make
local decisions at
the gateway on the farm
on how to do watering,
pesticides, and
chemicals on that field.
Again, it is something that is
motivated by a
real-world need somehow
goes in a very complex way
through this AI supercomputer.
By studying these, we learn
a huge amount about
how to build systems,
how to optimize them,
and how to make what
I said yesterday,
this one percent improvement,
how to make that really
matter and valuable.
I'm going to give
two more examples,
the next example this is again
is a chart that I didn't do,
it's a typical one of
these industry block charts,
but you really don't
have to understand it.
I'm just going to
tell you the story,
what this is about is a
water project in California.
Again, it's a collaboration.
FarmBeats is a collaboration
with many agricultural companies,
but also with
several universities.
Just yesterday evening
I was talking to Hakim
and Cornell who's actually,
Cornell is also collaborating
as part of FarmBeats.
This is a water
project in California
a collaboration with
the University of
California and Davis,
who are the masterminds
of water planning.
The problem there is really
that you would think
that water is,
well this is a simple problem
you collect all the
data and that's it,
but there are like 400 different
data sources that are
needed to reason about
water supply and
consumption in California.
One of the big
problems is leakages
where waste water because
some pipe is broken,
but just finding that out sounds
like technically from
our perspective easy but
really to get there you have to
integrate data from
multiple sources.
As it is some
of these sources don't
like to share their data,
because they are
afraid that they're
doing something wrong that is not
compliant or because they have
a competitive advantage as
a water supplier in
their particular region.
So what this really just shows
is the flow of the data,
how you kind of integrate it in
a trusted way so that
not every party,
how do you then analyze it?
Build different applications
and then how you
make at the very
right side some of
those results again openly
available to make decisions,
governmental decisions in
California about water.
The last example I want to show
is one that I'm
involved in myself,
and I'm saying it because we've
been talking about Blockchain.
I think everybody knows
this cartoon from,
I think it's from the early 90s.
It's a New Yorker,
on the Internet nobody knows
that you're a dog, right?
I love this cartoon for,
because I think I'm a dog
and I was always very
happy that the Internet
didn't know who I really was.
But there are cases where
you essentially do,
want to do something on
the Internet or you do
want to do something
digitally and you want
the other side to know
really this is me.
I'm actually going
through a very weird.
So IRS, I did my tax
return everything
is fine but IRS believes
that I'm spamming,
that I stole my own identity.
So, they didn't want to
pay me back my return,
and now they are trying to
somehow find a way that I can
convince them that I'm me.
So, this is actually an
interesting problem for the IRS,
but it's also and
maybe more interesting problem
in a much more mundane thing.
So let's say, think of the top,
I'm the second to the left,
I'm a person I have a phone
and I want to maybe not
even on the Internet,
I want to buy a glass of
champagne and I want to
pay for it digitally.
I want to somehow let's assume,
I forgot my driver's
license, my paper,
I want to somehow prove
digitally that I
am older than 21.
He wouldn't question
that I'm older than 21,
but let's just assume that he is
a very kind bar tender
that wants to
kind of be nice to me
and ask me and cause me.
So, that is the case so
essentially today you really
have to have the driver's license
there's no way for me to
prove digitally
that I'm 21, right?
That I can drink alcohol,
and because online
casinos might have
this problem but
they probably don't
care that much
about this problem.
So, there is a government
that issues IDs,
there is a bank that is
issue IDs credit cards are in
some sense IDs that
are issued by banks,
but we want to do
this all digital.
In China, it's all digital,
in the way that Alibaba or
$0.10 they issue the IDs
that you do for banking
and nobody else.
But we really don't want
to do that in our culture,
we don't want to trust
just one provider like Alibaba
to issue IDs for payments.
So, the idea here, and again,
it's a problem motivated
and it's open.
This whole work is
a standard by W3C,
but it has many computational
and systems aspects
that I want to get to that.
So what is happening here?
Essentially we are creating
these digital IDs everybody can
create digital IDs anytime
and they are stored
in Blockchains.
If there is a government ID,
well, it will be digitally
signed by the government.
The government can issue
it, can give it to me,
and I can choose
to participate in
this very open system and
a Blockchain system think of
like Bitcoin and
just put it there.
What I put there is not
my driver's license with
all the information,
what I would really put
there is just a hash.
Plus, I will put
there something and
a pointer that points to
that signed document.
So, think of all these IDs
or hashes of these IDs
in the block chain,
they will point to
some other distributed database
that will have again hashes
of where you can look up
those documents so that I can
prove digitally with
my driver's license,
but still no information
is revealed.
To make that all work,
on top of that we have what
we call the side-tree nodes
which take kind of
all the information
when there is an update, right,
I got a new credit card
after the old one expired,
I got a new driver's license or
there's some amendments to my,
I have a telephone contract
and I amended it
to have bigger data plan.
All of these requests come in,
they are batched, put together,
and then hashed and put into
the Blockchain in
a very efficient way.
Plus, there are
these side-tree nodes
that if the bartender
really wants to verify
my driver's license
and look at my age,
I will say, "Well,
I will present
my hash digital ID",
the bartender will
go to this system,
and it can go to any of
these side-tree nodes.
The ultimate source of
truth is the Blockchain,
will get a pointer
to the real drivers
license that I will
then present through
my phone and then the bartender
can validate that.
Again, the pattern is
very open system, many,
many parties collaborating, here
without any root of trust,
the Blockchain is a collaborative
way to create trust.
The caches and somehow they
can be operated by anybody,
you could operate one of
those caches on your phone
if you want to.
You don't have to
trust anybody there or
you have an economy of trust.
Then you implement a scenario,
real-world scenario user
human-centered scenario.
This is another
weird slice through
this global AI supercomputer
that we are all
collectively built.
So with that, I want to
close at least my part until
Sandy comes back on stage,
in the same way that I opened.
When I said our dreams
have come true, right?
I said well, what it is
that really we can
now change the world,
everything we do really matters
that's how I started it.
But, now when I say
I'm trying to give
a different perspective
on exactly that
same quotes that I made
yesterday morning.
We've created or there
is now a toy for us,
that is super, super fun
for us to play with.
And what this Faculty Summit is
about is come on let us play
together with this toy.
There are many ways you can
engage and play
with us with this.
The best way of
course for you is,
you have an idea
come to us and say,
"I want to do this.
I want to do water in California,
I want to fix
the water problem in
California and
southern California."
Right? Another way is you
send your students to us as
a part of the internship,
I hope you're doing that anyway,
but a that's a very
lightweight engagement.
But of course, we also
have other programs.
Sandy was mentioning
some of them,
we have visiting
researcher programs,
you can be a
consulting researcher.
We have all of these programs.
But the real message is we
have this wonderful toy,
let us play with it.
Thank you very much.